let's move on to the next one number
three the victim mindset
um let me grab that super chat from neo
thanks yeah i have a video on my channel
about prefaults law
and um you should go look it up just
search on um entrepreneurs in cars
uh on youtube and then put in what is
burfal's law and you'll come across a
video but essentially
uh robert berfult i think he was a
french doctor if i recall
i'm gonna have to go searching on
wikipedia but
he did a lot of um research on
the animal kingdom and you notice that
the female
in the animal kingdom uh determines the
length of the relationship let me just
quickly dig it up because
it's more eloquently put put the way
that uh
false law re oh he's a french surgeon
okay so burfold's law maintains that the
female not the male determines the
conditions of the animal
family where the female can derive no
benefit from association with the male
no such association
takes place or continues today we would
say relationship rather than
association but that's the essence of it
he's basically saying
the moment she no longer sees any value
in having you around
she will not be around essentially um
so you can go watch that video there's a
bit more of a breakdown on that topic
there
i found that uh to be an interesting
concept that
rings true and is consistent
[Music]
okay let's talk about victim mindset
i've seen this play out a lot
too many times when i say a lot too many
times they often brag on social media
about how strong independent
they are and how they don't need a man
okay we're talking about
the social narrative that we hear today
you know from
women but in the next breath they turn
to the government for handouts or their
children's father for financial support
now the children should be supported by
the father i don't
i don't question that the amount of
support that is often
redistributed from the father to the
mother uh
does not amount to what's required to
support
um children in most cases there's
there's no child in the world that needs
fifty thousand dollars a month yet there
are fathers paying fifty thousand
dollars a
month in child support right
um but that's how the courts operate
today so
back to this third point on mindset uh a
lot of mothers
a lot of single moms would complain to
me when i was dating about the father of
their children
often heard them use dispurging terms
like he's a loser he's dumb he's a
deadbeat he was beta or he was boring
any one of those were pretty common i
would often ask them why
they married him or had kids with him
and their face would turn to stone as if
to say
how dare you hold me accountable for my
choices
there's frankly no ownership when it
comes to choices
so you have to understand that this is
just going to be kind of par for the
course
it's not often exempted there are some
exemptions but it's not often exempted
um the other thing that you got to
understand with
the mindset component of this when you
get involved with single mommies is
um i've never met a single mother
that wasn't a self-proclaimed feminist
now i don't date feminist looking women
okay typically the optics
look something like short blue hair face
piercings tattoos
and rotund but there are
feminine looking women that are
self-proclaimed feminist still
you know they have they have feminine
looking feminists if you will
but the problem with them with the
ideology
is to identify as a feminist you must
have an oppressor
okay and every woman oppressed is a
victim when it comes to the feminist
logic
you can't you can't be a victim without
an oppressor
so there's something manufactured it
doesn't matter if it was
it was my dad when i was growing up my
husband was a loser he cheated on me he
was dumb he was unable to provide for
the family
you know insert whatever reason but
there's no ownership for well i chose to
you know wipe him up or husband him up
sort of thing there was no
ownership along that line that's just he
became inc
inadequate earlier to the point of ber
fault's law
again you know women will only keep a
guy around so long as he's useful
the moment he becomes or no longer is
useful to her
hypergamy kicks in she goes looking for
another opportunity
um and that's a requirement of survival
for women and her children um it's an
evolved
it's it's just hardwired and to be
honest with you
i'm just going to put it to you like
this there's nothing wrong with that
that's just the way they're hardwired
if they weren't hardwired that way they
wouldn't have survived they wouldn't
have the opportunity to
give their kids what they need so it's
it's just an adaptive
evolutionary type of behavior you just
have to understand it as a guy
that it's par for the course if you're
going to get involved with a single
mommy
uh let me grab a couple of these super
chats here real quick
santiago garcia there's no good reason
to get involved in a long-term
relationship with a single mom
it's like knowingly putting a handful
a hand in a bag full of snakes hoping to
find five cents
he's had some experience he's obviously
speaking from experience
um now the victim mindset requires her
to be unhappy unlucky and oppressed
i found out firsthand when i started
dating uh
dating after my divorce uh how these
women how hard done by
they'd claim that they were their kids
were
it was always somebody else's fault the
other problem with that too
is i mentioned earlier you have
responsibility
but you don't have authority if there's
a conflict and you're trying to enforce
boundaries with her kids
you're going to find that her kids are
also going to adopt this
ideal set this mindset one of the big
complaints i hear from a lot of guys
today
that were raised in single mother
households is the absence of a
strong masculine virtuous male
role model so they default to these
types of
beliefs and mindsets more specifically
the victim mindset
so give an example i try to enforce
a boundary once with my single mommy
type of relationship
kid acted out made up what was
nothing short of a lie basically
manufactured indignation
which is something that we've seen women
do um
and the mindset where did it come from
it's a learned behavior
you know kids learn these things you
know you can't you can't get mad
at a seven or a ten-year-old for
the behaviors or the decisions that they
make because
they're it's all learned behavior from
the parents so where do you think he's
gonna get that from
right he or she's gonna get it from the
mommy so
you have to understand um that's a
strong element of one of the
uh risks that you're gonna have to deal
with so if something doesn't go their
way they'll emotionally manipulate the
mother
and of course she turns into mama bear
and she swoops in and wants to protect
those kids from
the big bad guy that doesn't happen to
be the kid's father but
he's the useful idiot that can you know
be an
atm when she needs resources or help
with things
you